my name is Daniel I work at data dog and
I'm about to reveal to you today the
terrible secret of service are you ready
here we go we're gonna start with a meme
you might remember this one
there is no cloud it's just someone
else's computer
well that's from 2016 as I said we're
gonna update it for today there is no
service it's just functions as a service
or fasts all right now here's the first
big reveal of this presentation faz is
not magic
all right event you have an architecture
anybody remember this have you done some
ETL or batch processing since like the
1980s you've probably encountered
event-driven architecture well that's
the architecture upon which functions as
a service or built there's nothing new
Under the Sun resource utilization still
a thing
you don't get to hand wave it away you
still have to think about CPU you still
have to think about memory and as an
added bonus you now have to think about
time how much time do you need those
resources you're purchasing compute
you're having resources allocated to
your jobs and as anybody who's ever used
a mainframe could tell you that sounds
familiar
speaking of mainframes guess who's still
a player that's right IBM IBM has cloud
functions you can use them today it's
not bad
so does Microsoft so does Google so does
AWS except in AWS this case they call it
lambda presumably because someone there
is a really big half-life fan now the
incumbent providers are kind of like
dump trucks for a given workload for
given size a truck for given amount of
time you need that truck for it barely
matters who you rent it from nonetheless
there are some differences the hardware
that drives those services is going to
change from provider to provider the
operating system that the functions run
in changes from provider to provider and
crucially the language you get to write
your functions in changes from provider
to provider but in the real world the
hardware completely opaque you don't get
to choose it probably a trade secret you
don't get to know in the operating
system you don't get to choose it either
very low configurability in any case so
the crucial differentiator becomes
language support in Amazon you get
JavaScript and Java and Python and
c-sharp some others and it runs on top
of the lob OS Linux so that's cool
in Microsoft you get JavaScript and C
sharp and F sharp and bash and a bunch
of other stuff actually if you really to
go and support it in Google you get
JavaScript in IBM you get JavaScript but
you also get docker so that's kind of
fun now look I ran the numbers forgiving
workloads forgiven scoped a job
forgiving what you want to do there's
not a lot of difference between the
major providers all right what does that
mean commodity pricing is in effect in
other words the market has spoken so how
do you pick a provider well if you got a
right at an f-sharp Google's not your
friend and if you're already part of the
AWS walled garden and you're very happy
there there's no reason to leave it and
finally if you're a Microsoft shop
writing Microsoft software with a
Microsoft IDE for Microsoft customers
don't bother rocking the boat the
important thing to remember here is in
service there is no magic all right
you still have to think about hardware
constraints you still have to think
about software constraints and now
crucially you have to think about
perhaps more intimately than ever your
workloads your software your customer
base all right that my friends is the
terrible secret of serverless there's no
hand waving thank you very much
[Applause]